can think of positive as going forward
okay are going up or increasing or
earning money say for example these are
all examples of like positive numbers
whereas negative numbers you could think
about maybe going backwards or down or
decreasing or spending okay so money is
going you know maybe out of your bank
account something like that another way
to think about it okay and we'll talk
about this in a little bit is you know
the balance between positive and
negatives so you can compare two numbers
and see if you're going more forward or
going more backwards and we'll talk
about that in just a minute we're also
going to discuss how to work with these
numbers on the number line everyone has
their own preferred method I'll show you
mine but we'll look at a couple
different examples and let's get started
so two plus negative three so what you
could think of is you could think of
alright I'm starting at the first number
I'm starting at two right here okay and
I'm adding a negative three steps I'm
going backwards three so I'm starting at
two and I'm going back one two three now
I'm at negative one okay if you want to
use my let's say earning and spending
example you could say well maybe you
earned two dollars but you spent three
dollars overall for the day you spent
one dollar more okay then you earned
okay so your bank account decreased by
one dollar okay so that's one way to
look at is on the number line you start
here at the first number and if you're
adding a negative number you're going to
go to the left or backwards if you're
adding a positive number it's like
taking steps forward okay but sometimes
when you're working with really large
numbers it would take you a long time to
count okay all of those places on the
number line you'd run out of time okay
and fingers and so forth so now let's
say you have a negative four plus two
right you're starting at negative four
so let's just say over here and you're
adding two so you're going to the right
one two you can see we're adding ending
up at negative two okay now that's one
way to look at it another way to look at
it is let's go over here to
this old-fashioned scale okay where
you're weighing something okay you've
got the four negatives here okay so you
can think of the negatives on your left
okay so negatives okay there's so many
pounds with K on the scale on the left
side negative four you've got two on the
positive side which way do you think
that skills going to tip well it's
heavier on the negative side it's going
to tip to the negative side how much
more negative okay or how much more
weight is on the left side the negative
side then on the right side we can see
that this side the negative side is
heavier by two so it's going to be
negative two if you put one two three
four and one two okay like that okay
then what's going to happen let me see
if I can just adjust this a little bit
so say you have four negatives okay and
two positives two of these positives are
going to cancel out with two of these
negatives okay and so it's heavier you
can see by two on the negative side so
that's one way to look at it and this is
actually my preferred method okay it's
just looking at this scale and comparing
the two numbers so over here are
negative three plus negative one if you
want the number line method you start
here at negative three you're adding
negative one that means you're going
back one step and you're gonna end up at
negative four if you use my scale
example you say hmm I'm stacking up
three bricks here on the left side plus
another brick this is going to tilt to
the negative side negative for three
plus one for negatives okay this last
example we've got three numbers seven
plus negative two plus negative five
okay you can do this in any order
because addition is commutative you can
change the order but let's just do it
one at a time so 7 plus negative two if
we go to my example here which one do we
have more of the positives or the
negatives positives right so that means
that okay for getting our scale out
we're saying hmm I've got two on the
Left seven on the right it's going to
tip to the positive side by five because
it's heavier by five so in a sense I
subtracted because I was trying to
figure out how much
war was on the one side than the other
and there's more positive so it's going
to be positive now we've got five plus
negative five you can see those are
going to balance out exactly it's like
if you watch forward five steps and then
you walk backwards five steps you're
going to be right where you started you
traveled zero distance okay so they
actually cancel each other out and you
get zero so think about maybe what your
preferred method is for working with
positive and negative numbers I prefer
the scale method and comparing to seeing
which one I have more of okay or if
they're both on the same side I add them
together okay or if you like this going
forward and back up and down increasing
decreasing or think about maybe earning
and spending money so a few different
ways to look at positive and negative
numbers and the next video we'll talk
about how to subtract positive and
negative numbers I'll see you in the
next video